welcome back a tragic update out of
Savannah Georgia law enforcement
believes they have found the remains of
a missing 20-month-old in a landfill
Clinton Simon's mother reported him
missing in October now Leilani Simon is
under arrest after an exhaustive surge
that lasted weeks the Chatham County
Police Department started searching a
local landfill the department says
officers combed through more than one
million pounds of trash over 30 days
before finding human remains the FBI is
now doing DNA and other testing at its
lab in Quantico authorities have not
released information about cause of
death but have said they believe
Quentin's body was left in a dumpster
this is a heartbreaking development for
everyone who loved Quentin for the many
people who came to know him after his
disappearance and for our department
when we first received the call that
Quentin was missing
we were hopeful that we would find him
alive and unharmed
but as we have been telling you for
weeks all of our evidence
pointed to his mother being responsible
for his death and disappearance and his
remains being found in the landfill she
doesn't deserve a Thanksgiving quite
frankly if I can go off Off Script a
little bit Quentin deserves that
Terry arrested for murder then what are
presumed to be her child's remains are
found how will an evaluation of these
remains affect charges and potential
bail well you know now that they have
found the body and this is a horrible
case it truly is to see that a mother
could be held responsible for the death
of a 20-month year old child but now
that they have the body they can do all
of this DNA they can make sure they try
to determine with a medical examiner
what was the manner and cause of death
and of course if they tie it back to the
mother then they have what they need but
it's going to be hard of course she is
Presumed Innocent but she's probably the
last one who was with the child it's not
as though the child got up and walked
away so it's a sad case Brian yeah Matt
cause of death and manner of death are
the major findings we're looking for in
this coming autopsy what will they tell
us and what other questions need to be
answered
well Brian as you know there there are
five manners of death you know accident
natural causes suicide homicide and
undetermined I mean I think the question
here is this and was this an accident or
is this homicide and they're also going
to look for if it in fact it is homicide
what was the cause of death what was its
Suffocation was it blunt force trauma
all these uh findings can answer
questions as part of this investigation
and they're also going to know maybe a
time frame when did this death occur so
there's a lot that can be derived from
this autopsy and these findings will be
extremely important in this
investigation yeah the hope is that we
get those answers soon and of course
when we do we'll bring them to you our
law and crime daily viewers coming up on
lawn crime daily two more celebrities
headed to federal prison for financial
fraud just how much time a judge handed
it down two reality stars Todd and Julie
Chrisley plus reality TV stars Todd and
Julie Chrissy will spend the next
several years in a federal prison a
judge sentence taught to 12 years and
his wife Julie to seven the two were
found guilty of bank fraud and tax
evasion prosecutors said the Chrisleys
took out 30 million dollars in
fraudulent bank loans to fund their
lifestyle the couple presented himself
as real estate Moguls on the reality TV
shows Chrisley Knows Best Uncle Chrisley
said they did nothing wrong and someone
else had control of their finances
they'll report to prison after the
holidays
we told you on Monday a federal judge
sentence Elizabeth Holmes to 11 years in
prison with three years of Subaru's
release after that Holmes was convicted
of fraud charges after she claimed to
investigate investors that her company
theranos had created a revolutionary new
blood testing technology Holmes was
ordered to report to prison in April